Ron is with us in Chicago hi Ron welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Ron thanks
for taking my call Sherman what's up I
enjoy your show a lot and I have three
children that I was hoping to talk about
my daughter is 24 I have two boys 19 and
22 my daughter's doing great she
graduated college and has a marketing
degree she's on her third job and making
great partners my boys on the other hand
don't have a sense of urgency and
responsibility that my daughter has a 19
year old struggled through senior year
high school he didn't graduate he has
four classes to make up online and he's
not really moving forward with that you
could have a part-time valet job but
he's just doing enough to survive and
it's really a problem I can't seem to
get him motivated where does he live
four year old son he was in home with me
okay well I can get out a mother yeah I
have some other situations as well my
I've been divorced for the past 12 years
I've had custody of my kids and my lags
wife thought when suicide two years ago
that's so it's been a tough situation
for him sure emotionally as well but
I've tried a number of things to get him
motivated and it's very difficult
grateful lot he'll come home drawn
scared times and he's just a big
challenge my other boy my 22 year old
he's working pretty hard to small jobs
but he's not really investing in his
future does he live at home as I open to
sit down he's home as well and you know
I'd like to sit down with my boys and
put some goals and a strategy together
but I don't seem to want to do that what
sounds like the 22 year olds a lot
further along right and as at least he's
working he's moving in the right
direction maybe it maybe isn't being the
brightest guy all the time but the other
ones he's off the ranch
well yeah so I would approach them
differently because there are different
points I've got 22 year-old son he just
left 10 minutes ago to go to call go
back to college for his final semester
in college getting ready to graduate and
so I've been there done that you know
not not with the exact same issues but I
mean I've got kids this age as my point
so you know I guess the thing is that I
think that you've allowed these two
young men to become confused and it's on
you
they're confused that this is how life
works and you've allowed them to be
confused because you've not straightened
them out on how life works the way life
works is you you need to learn
continuously and you need to work
continuously in order to get traction in
order to get ahead I am really
heartbroken and sorry for the loss of
their mom and but that does not give
them that does not mean that I quit
loving them and allow them to stop
bathing and stop brushing their teeth
which is effectively what you're saying
I mean and you know these are just
different kinds of misbehavior when
they're ten years old
we have to make them bathe and brush
their teeth when they're 19 we have to
make sure that they know how to work and
that they don't come home drunk
otherwise they don't get to live here
and it's not because I mean or because
I'm worried about me it's I love you son
and and your behaviors are going to
destroy your life and I will not provide
you shelter while you destroy your life
because then I'm participating in the
destruction of your life which would
mean that I don't love you right and I
love you too much so here's the deal
here's the deal Bubba if you are going
to live here here are the rules you are
going to finish these classes in the
next 90 days you are going to get steady
work and you are not coming home drunk
any more if you want to live somewhere
else you can figure that out but I am
NOT going to participate in your
destruction because I love you and so
these are your noodle guidelines and
he's going to get mad and that's fine he
can leave right and that's not tough
love that's love
right I've set those guidelines you
haven't held to that seat well I've
tried to butt out
don't get out yes I started that process
where I put together an eviction letter
and good sorry that process he doesn't
seem to take that serious well he's
going to have to move physically have
him removed from the residence if he
can't get it he doesn't believe you you
know why because you've never followed
through on stuff that's why he's doing
this crap he doesn't think you're gonna
follow through because in the past you
haven't followed through am I wrong on
some cases okay
all right some kids you know I'll tell
you what it'll help the 22 year old when
you move the 19 year old out it'll get
his attention that's true and so he's
either gonna do this stuff or he's gone
and if he doesn't believe me I can move
him by Friday he'll come home the locks
will be changed in his crap will being a
pile in the driveway
mm-hmm I can fix this now I don't want
to be that harsh but if the kids not
getting it I'm going to continue to turn
up the heat until he's completely
freakin on fire for his own good it
doesn't it doesn't hurt me and it
doesn't hurt you it's he's establishing
habit patterns here which is I'm going
to be ignorant and lazy and drunk these
are not habit patterns that cause you to
win at life absolutely and and I love
him too much to let him do that I'm not
going to finance ignorant lazy and drunk
this is an animal house this is not
where we live and I'm not Dean wormer
you know that's not how we're doing this
so I you just that that's how I'm doing
it because this is this is a money issue
because it has to do with work ethic and
it has to do with behaviors which create
your life and around that is the whole
subject of money and so just one dad to
another that's what I'm telling you I
would do I'm going to be kind I'm gonna
be gentle I'm not gonna yell we're not
gonna cuss we're not gonna have a fight
but you are going to leave my home if I
say you are this is my home
it's not yours and if you're so freakin
brilliant go figure it out but I'm not
going to participate
paid in your destruction I love you too
much to assist you in destroying your
life and not habit patterns the track
you're on that's what you're taking and
I'm going to help you have some problems
because you don't have enough problems
right now
that's what my friend Henry cloud says
in the book boundaries he says you don't
have any problems you get away with them
everything and so I'm going to help you
have some problems because right now the
deal is Ron you've got problems you're
19-year olds I got any he's got a warm
bed and Miss behavior is completely
allowed and you need to help him have
some problems and that's that is an act
of love and it's not really tough love
everybody runs around this tough love
stuff it's not tough love it's just love
it's tough to do to love people well
sometimes it's hard to do and sometimes
it requires taking strong actions but
that intimates is it tough love like a
kid do their homework to make a brush
their teeth to make them save to make
them give if that's tough love I think I
just called it parenting that's what I
called it when we were doing it this is
the Dave Ramsey chef
you